teams will get better teams will get
worse teams will fix their mistakes
that's today's draft and I have a
feeling that since I haven't received
the oh yes with the quiets so yeah I got
a I got an answer your question from you
what do you got okay here we go and I
haven't even read this so sorry I should
have previewed it a little to see if it
was too hard I could have adjusted but
the hell with you I hope it is too hard
dak Prescott had a perfect passer rating
158 point three verse the New York
Giants
who is the only other Cowboys QB to pull
that off in a regular season game wow
it's just a wild guess
right totally well yes totally right I
mean as long as it's a Cowboys
quarterback I mean it is a fairly narrow
uniform is a quarterback yes there's a
little bit one that's under the radar
I'll help you with that okay it's not I
don't I don't want I don't want any okay
let me go Gary Hogeboom
okay go good one for them to the radar
you were wrong about that that would be
Craig Morton the Craig Morton yes who
who ended up actually playing the
Cowboys in the Superbowl as the
quarterback of the Broncos which is
actually a kind law and it had one of
the worst performances ever not a
perfect passer rating against the
Cowboys in that twenty seven to ten loss
in Super Bowl number I always think of
that play in that game to where the guy
for the Cowboys catches the ball in the
end zone the ball just like that was not
a touchdown right I mean that we got to
go back we should go back and replay it
let's call our river on and just let's
redo the record books I don't know
you're talking about getting the two
teams together yeah that's replay back
out there Craig Morton and let's go at
it again all right what's your first
pick okay my first pick okay and our
draft is teams players that can fix
their mistakes okay so I am gonna go
with the New York Giants is number one
okay just because this is the most
glaring thing that happened this weekend
to where they can fix this mistake and
it's real easy it's a real easy fix
hmm oh that's right get the ball say
Kwan Barclay the ball more get them the
frickin ball more how does he only get
11 rushes how does he only get 14
touches in general I mean
that can be fixed for sure they just
gotta find more creative ways pass game
run game they got to ride him a little
harder than just 11 carries he's just
too talented as we saw in the game in
general so again I don't know if that's
gonna lead to a victory but I certainly
think getting the ball in his hands
increases their chances of a victory as
far as the New York Giants and gonna
help out the rest of that offense for
sure he's the best running back in
football and they just can't give him
the ball that few of times and I given a
given football game yeah I think that's
the obvious first pick here because this
is the guy through whom the offense is
supposed to run right I thought they had
figured that out late last year
apparently they haven't it's on Pat
Shermer to make full advantage of a guy
who is arguably the best running back in
the NFL right now but it's hard hard for
him to prove it if he's not getting the
opportunities he's got to get the ball
more than 11 times the offense has to
run through him and if he's not running
the ball he needs to be catching the
ball but he needs to be the tone setter
for the Giants if they're gonna have any
chance to win more games then they lose
all right not a bad choice kind of
obvious yeah Tripp now we've gone from
the rigged coin toss to the rigged
trivia question historian Frank Morton
give me a guy that's played in the last
50 years for crying out loud all right
I'm gonna go with Chicago Bears because
it's impossible for them to continue to
be as bad as they were last Thursday
night on offense and we talked so much
about Vic Fangio the former Bears
defensive coordinator now the coach of
the Broncos welcoming the Bears to
Denver well for as much as Fangio knows
the offensive personnel the offense of
personnel knows Fangio and they know
what Fangio does and you could argue the
Bears defensive personnel better right
now than what's left from the Broncos
Super Bowl 50 championship team Nick
Chubb our Bradley Chubb rather and Von
Miller no sacks last week although they
may be even more determined to get to
Mitchell true Biscay but I think that
that with the extra time to get ready
think about that extra time for the
Bears short week for the Broncos that
also makes it easier for the Bears to
fix their mistakes and go against a guy
that that Matt naggy the coach of the
Bears should have a feel for how this is
gonna play out so I think it's easy for
the easier for the Bears and I thought
it was going to be to get their footing
back and erase the the
first loss of the season they
experienced last week yeah I mean I
don't disagree with you there I mean
they got talent and they got a good
coach they got a good offensive line
you'd think they'd be able to fix their
problems true Brisky certainly needs to
play better it wasn't perfect my big
question and I know we talked about this
last Friday after the game I just again
I just don't know what they are on
offense right we had that conversation
and I got to see that because you know
there's got to be something again that
forces the defense's hand in a football
game to open up everything else and the
Bears kind of do everything but there's
not one thing I look at and go oh that
is amazing they do that and that's gonna
give defense as an issue they got to
figure out that one thing and I think
they will do that so not a bad pick by
you they were certainly on my list I'm
gonna go with the Cleveland Browns as my
next pick yeah the Cleveland Browns
offense especially that's the that's the
unit I'm going with the offense you know
they can fix the mistakes that they made
in week two one
you know Baker Mayfield has shown he's
able to take criticism going back to the
drawing board keep fighting get better
gosh did the day I was there might get
practice in Cleveland during August I
was supposed to talk to him and
interview him he didn't have a great
practice and he wanted to lock himself
in the film room and and kind of beat
himself up and go over the things he did
wrong and they told me that's kind of
status quo for what Baker Mayfield does
if a practice doesn't meet up to his
expectations so I think you can fix that
of course they have talent and the big
thing Mike and you've heard me say this
a little already get back Bay one
football games last year when Freddie
kitchens took over because he was run
first he got into more power run
formations and he played play action
pass and took deep shots off of that
they ran the ball to Nick Chubb 17 times
on Sunday and that at base level looks
okay but like six of those runs or seven
of those runs when the game was over it
was late in the fourth quarter and it
was over they were just token runs like
let's get out of here let's keep the
clock moving and going they became one
to one-dimensional shotgun and I think
Freddie kitchen got a little enamored
with who I have Jarvis and I got Baker
and I got Odell Beckham jr. and we're
gonna throw the ball over the place and
let's not forget that they have a great
running back and
can control the game and help their
quarterback if they do run the ball a
little bit more you know that gets back
to the point that there's only one
football how do you keep all those guys
happy if you are gonna commit to a power
running game
odo Beckham juniors gonna want the ball
Jarvis Landry is gonna want the ball
these are guys who on different teams in
the early years of their career they had
phenomenal numbers yes of catches you
you can't get both guys the football as
much as they want to be on the same team
only one guy is going to be catching
that pass and if they're running the
ball running the ball running the ball
neither's catching them well yeah they
but it's not that they need to like just
run the ball all day long too they just
can't be in the shotgun
oh we're gonna spread it out all day
long you know they have some good tight
ends there there are a better run
blocking offensive line than pass
blocking offensive line and yeah they
might not get as many catches but I
think the quality of their catches the
explosive plays and everything that we
want to see in highlight reels that will
go up if they kind of force the
defense's hand a little bit to stop the
run game it's gonna lead to more
favorable matchups on the outside and
they can put those two receivers on the
field with two tight ends and a Nick
Chubb and really put teams in a New
England type bind oh wait man that oh
now and David joke hoose pull it out I
don't trust my tight in to cover I mean
my linebacker to cover this set up what
do i do oh now the next play they're on
a power run formation ooh this is tough
they have the pieces to kind of make
teams uncomfortable they don't need to
be to reinvent the wheel they're in
Cleveland we didn't know what to make of
the Atlanta Falcons coming into the
season offense coordinator new special
teams coordinator Dan Quinn serving is
the defensive coordinator they kind of
walked into a buzzsaw in Minnesota it's
always tough to go into that building
and win it's set up the way that roof is
pitched and the way the angles are the
sound ends up being directed at the
opposing sideline it is an unpleasant
experience when you are in that new
building still in 3 years old in
Minnesota and also home opener blocked
punt on that first drive by the Falcons
the Vikings score touchdown and that
just sets the tone ugly interception
from Matt Ryan on the next drive right
at 14 nothing how do you climb out of
that weak one in another team's building
it is not easy to do they did try they
had a nice drive after it was 14 nothing
but but it never got clicking for them
until the game was out of hand I think
this is a team that can settle down and
I know it look look big stage against
the Eagles on Sunday Night Football but
I think they can settle down get back to
0 and 0 start the game from scratch and
if you avoid those big mistakes early
you're going to be in a position where
you can hang around and we know the
Falcons have played the Eagles tough
even though the Falcons lost to them
last year in week 1 they lost him in the
divisional round of the playoffs the
Falcons have played them tough and and
this may be an opportunity for the
Falcons to to change a very ugly
narrative coming out of week 1 and I
think they've got the personnel to do it
yeah I don't disagree there Matt Ryan
was on my list too to fix those problems
but you know you said it too early
turnovers they're down 14 nothing then
they dropped down the field they're in
field goal position and they run the
ball and Devonta Freeman fumbles unlike
the 18 or 19 yard line going in and even
saying that there they are in the third
quarter it's only 21 nothing and they're
first and goal with the 2 or 3 yard line
and Matt Ryan throws just in horrible
interception in the back of the end zone
that really kind of put the nail in the
coffin and that was it so I hear you
there they're certainly potential there
for them to fix that and enough good
players Jaguars defense will be my round
3 pick ok well yeah what what the
Jaguars a team that I believe they can
fix their mistakes and improve the week
- yeah I do
first off they're not playing the Kansas
City Chiefs and freaking Patrick mahomes
and Andy Reed who's an absolute
mastermind on by weeks and first week of
the season that's the damn scariest
first week matchup and you can then you
can hope for if you're a defense damn I
got to deal with all that talent
Patrick mahomes throwing balls
everywhere and that I think that Jaguars
defense is still extremely talented and
I have worries about that Texans offense
in general that it's to Hopkins walk
Watson
oriented and I'm still I'm worried about
their past protection issues they're in
tech in Houston I'm going with the
Panthers I think the Panthers should
have one week one against the Rams I'm
not willing to let that one go because I
thought the Panthers would win they get
the Buccaneers Jameis Winston has lost
12 in a row on the road Christian
McCaffrey a beast too many mistakes made
last week by the Panthers you need to
iron those out if they do they should
win this one easily and we'll have a
different vibe about the pain
there's heading into week three alright
that's it for the draft we have to take
a quick break when we return Chris you
suggested yesterday you'd be interested
to see the injury report for the Houston
Texans as it relates to quarterback
deshaun Watson yeah still O'Brien has
given us a sneak peek we'll talk about
that one pft live continues right after
this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports